hello everyone and welcome to round 12
of the 2018 Tata Steel chess tournament
a game where Carlsen once again create
something out of nothing but before I
show that game I would just like to
quickly show you a game between Gawain
Jones and Jacques de Lima media of as
that game lasted only eight moves I
don't want to make an entire video about
it but I would just like like to show it
to you and hear your opinion about the
game here going Jones opened with e4 we
have E 5 by Mahmoud yar of Knight to f3
Knight to f6 the Petrov defence Knight
captures d6 all standard theory Knight
to f3 Knight captures on e4
we have c4 Knight to c6 Knight to c3
Knight captures we have D captures and
here mama D I've played g6 Bishop to g5
was played and after Bishop to e7 Gawain
Jones played Bishop to h6 mama D are
quickly responded with Bishop to f8 we
had Bishop to g5 Bishop to e7 Bishop to
h6 Bishop to f8 and Bishop to g5 and in
this position both players agreed to a
draw now what's interesting about this
that Madeira was in the lead so why
would he take a draw okay he does have
the black pieces but he is a hundred and
fifty rating points higher rated and
booing Jones and this was like black
isn't worse here he can still continue
the game
either either now he you know he has a
kind of player that will play f6 and
after Queen e2 check maybe play King to
f7 or simply Bishop to e7 and after this
Bishop goes to h6 then played Bishop to
e6 and maybe go for a queenside castle
but for some reason he agreed to a draw
here I'm interested what do you think
about this why did the mama dr have
accepted row here and the why did Duane
Jones a force this variation as he does
have the white pieces so I mean okay you
did get a draw against a higher rated
opponent but why why are you here if if
this is how you want to play chess so
let's get back to our original game
Carlson has the white pieces and he
faces Maxine Matlock off we have 'if r
e4 c5 matakohe goes for the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3
p6 d for sink after Sun before and night
capture Sun d4 Knight to c6 we have a
Knight to c3 Queen to c7 and Bishop to
e3 the time-honored variation we have a
six this is the master code variation of
the time out of Queen to d2 and Queen to
Bishop to b4 f4 by Carlson Knight to f6
now I'm that he for pawn since the the
knight is pinned Bishop to d3 defending
d4 pawn and Knight to a5 now what ideas
of coming to see for forcing either
either capturing the dark square Bishop
or forcing Bishop characters and c4
grabbing the light square bishop so
across some place a3 we have Bishop
characters on c3 Queen captures and c3
Queen captures and me captures on c3 d5
you capture son b5 he captures on d5 and
Knight to b3 by Carlsen with the idea
that if Knight captures night Carson
will improve his pawn structure when the
C pawn recapture some b3 so Knight to c4
by matlock off and we have Bishop to D
for not allowing Knights to capture the
bishop Knight to e4 and here Carlsen
play tonight to c5 it's took matlock of
some 25 maybe 26 minutes in this
position to decide his next move and he
played Knight captures I will have
Bishop captures and here Bishop to d7
preparing a queenside castle cost an
immediately castles Queen side we have
queenside castle by one lock off and now
comes Bishop captures on c4 d captures
on c4 and Bishop to b6 and rook to e8
and this is a very very cool position
because as you can see this pawn on c4
is very weak Carlson does have CC pawns
but he will very soon win this bond and
one other thing you have to consider
that these are opposite colored bishops
so if the ropes get exchanged it's very
likely this is going to be a draw so we
have rope to d4 by crossing going after
the c4 pawn and here metal Cove has to
make a choice he will either play Bishop
rook to e6 going after the bishop and b6
or he may try to defend at the pond with
a move like a Bishop to b5 but
Carson has rook H to d1 doubling up on
the D file and with this rooks anga
eyeing the b8 square and the bishop also
protecting it that King is stuck there
for the rest of the game and it's only
carlson who can make any progress in
this game so instead of Bishop to b5
after this rook to d4 move
Matlock of this has to go for up to e6
better to get some activity rook
captures on c4 would check rogue blocks
the c6 rook captures and Bishop captures
and here the the bishop is attacking the
G to pawn but Carlsen plays rook to d1
and what do you play here here it took
Matlock off I think again some 12
minutes maybe even more maybe even 15
and after that he decided to capture the
GG up on another idea he might have
tried is maybe maybe playing a move like
H 5 H 5 and after g3 maybe going Bishop
to d7 taking control of these light
squares for example h5 g3 and authorship
to d7 it's a pretty good control of
these light squares here but ok after
rook to d1 he decided to capture cross
and plate rook to g1 and here
Bishop to e4 was played here you did
polgár was in the studio of the Tata
Steel chess tournament and she said ok
Bishop to b4 but maybe even Bishop to d5
as you'll see that this also isn't
without merit
after for example Bishop to d5 and cross
and captures now for example h5 and now
the bishop here is guarding the f7 pawn
and this rook isn't really that big of a
threat here on the seventh rank now even
the King can enter the game
Matlock Oh on the other hand after up to
g1 decided to play bush appear Carlsen
captured and we have Bishop to g6 now
locking the rook and here f5 is an idea
forcing Bishop to capture and then
capture the f7 pawn but Carson doesn't
go for this he plays a 4 and this was
the first move that cousin actually
spent time to play he - he spent some 12
minutes on this move rook to f8
now if f5 comes then seems like rook is
protecting the spawn
not really as you'll see Boston police
came to be - and we have King 37 Matlock
also wants to get his King into the game
but here cousin does play f5 so what
they do Bishop captures and out rook to
c5 kicking this row away from f8 so rook
will capture on f7 rook to c8 attacking
the bishop but first rook captures would
check King King e6 and our rook to e7
check King to f6 and Bishop to b4 a5 is
played you can't capture the pawn as the
rock would be hanging on e7 so Bishop to
a3 here rook the c-4 was played as
Carson is detecting the b7 pawn now
Motoko is detecting the a4 pawn Carlsen
captures the metallic of captures and
rook to a7 either saying to Matlock off
either your rook will stay here inactive
as long as it wants or you will move it
and I will capture the a51 so you don't
really want to keep your look there and
one other thing that Carlson saw is that
rook h4 is impossible going after this
point because of Bishop to e7 check
picking up the rook so this is very nice
in Carlson's favor after rook to a7 rook
to e4 was played Carlson captures and
here
Carlson is up to pawns but as you can
see rook rook e2 is coming and now there
is no way to defend this point so Matt
will grab one point also the h2 point is
attacked so Bishop to d6 defending the
h2 pawn and out comes the Bishop
captures on c2 and here Matlock who is
threatening some discoveries but Carson
simply pushes c4 as all of his pieces
and this h2 pawn is on a dark square so
no worries there came to e6 here we have
rook to a6 and here this is move 39
Carson's 40th move and the Matlock of
needs to make one more move to reach
down control and he was below 5 minutes
I think at at the time he played this
move he had like 1 minute left on the
clock so he definitely had to decide
what to do and best move here is
probably Bishop to e for the
the post problems for this pawn so it
can't really be pushed further but in
time control he played Bishop to a5 dis
discovers a check the crossings King
King to c3 and now that the time control
has been reached he was granted more
time on the clock now he plays Bishop to
a4 as the bishop really does belong on
e4 more than on f5
King deformed by Carlsen King to f5 and
here we have rook to a5 check King g4 c5
now we have Bishop to f3 and rook to a7
attacking the h7 pawn h6
and here Carlsen plays rook to h7 again
attacking that pawn rook to e4 check
King to d3 and rook to e6 now and here
we have King to see for now the King
will go up the board either here or or
maybe 35 if the bishop moves Bishop to
c6 not allowing the King to go up the
board but now comes rock to c7 kicking
kicking the bishop back bishop trade h1
and now kink the b5 we have h5 and now
comes rock the g7 check and I believe it
was somewhere before this move somewhere
in this position that as I saw a tweet
on Twitter that the Norwegian a super
computer sassy or I believe the name is
sassy predicted that Carlson will that
not cause him will but that White has a
fourth checkmate in 28 moves I don't
know if it was exactly in this position
or maybe a move before this position but
that White had a fourth checkmate in 28
moves and I don't have access to this
variation but maybe some of you do so if
you have access to this very nice force
forcing variation in 28 moves do share
in the comments I will add it in the
description so rook the g7 by Carlson
and here you probably want to play King
to f5 you know bring the King closer to
the action but it's hard to say probably
King to f5 in this position King to h4
was played and this looks pretty
terrible
now this king is completely cut off from
the game and here it seems Carlson
missed a force the wind that was
actually very forcing the skin to h4
move seems to be a great blunder here
Bishop to d7 seems to win the game
immediately after Bishop d7 check you
can either capture it but that then
you're just lost
after King to h3 you have this rook to
g3 check and now the only move the King
has screen captures on h2 and now you
play Bishop back to d6 and as you can
see the King has nowhere to go so your
first instinct is okay I'll capture the
bishop and then I'll grab the rook but
if you do this rook captures pawn
captures in King captures rook then you
get d7 and there is no more way for this
point to be stopped this is completely
winning one other idea after this Bishop
to d6 move since you can't capture it
you want to place the rook somewhere
where it will be protected after Carson
delivers I discovered the chip the only
square for this is e for as the bishop
is not protecting the rook on e4 but now
simply rook the d3 check the King has to
move King moves and now simply push c6
rook has to go back to block the point
c7 is coming rook to c8 and now comes
Bishop to e5 the threat of courses rook
to d8 and after any move black place you
simply play roof to d8 and here black
will have to sacrifice a pawn he he will
capture it Bishop captures and it's
completely winning position for white as
this pawn can never be promoted the
bishop is guarding the h2 square
Wiseman's him to play rook to e8 and
there is no way this pawn is ever
becoming a queen but after king to h4
Carson had a different idea
he played rook to g1 we have Bishop to 8
now getting the best part of the way
keep the b6 now rook to e2 we have King
to c7
Bishop to d5 and rope to g3 now the idea
behind rook to g3
it's it's you know it has a lot of a lot
of ideas because one of the ideas is
actually just a play for example King to
d8 and then
to e7 and if the rook ever moved this
would be checkmate and even if the rook
doesn't move black will have to
sacrifice a rook for this bishop so here
Bishop to h1 was played and here Carlsen
plays rook to c3 he doesn't go for the
fancy line rope the c3 we have King to
g4 and now c6 and it was finally in this
position that Matlock over resigned to
the game is it too soon well it it does
appear to be too soon but it's really
not so you can simply play king 37 here
pulled upon and it's game over
and one other thing is that even if you
push and black sacrifices the bishop for
the pawn white is still winning as the
pawn the pawn on h2 is protected the
bishop is guarding it and after Carlson
wins this point then this bishop is is a
dark square bishop and the queening
square is also a dark square so even if
the rooks get exchanged this pawn is of
the right color and this is completely
winning so there it is a very nice game
from round 12 the 2008 year 18 Tata
Steel chess tournament Magnus Carlsen is
once again tied in first place with 80
and a half points with a nice giri who
also achieved a very nice victory
against Bhaskar and Adam and I will also
show the game and it's a very
unfortunate for soccer manager of that
he decided to go for that quick draw
against the going Jones but you know he
probably thought that since both
crossing and Gary probably won't win
their games today cousin I don't know
what he thought but both cautioning
everyone their games so now he's half a
half point behind him but he does have
the white pieces tomorrow so even if he
wins tomorrow he might still catch up to
them so yeah I do hope you enjoyed this
game I would like to thank Oscar because
he move Karl's ipil again it has vast
sea and still boy clock for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon